oh this is really good - thank you honey
[Music]
Alex you I'm Lorenzo I come from rum and
eat le hey guys I'm cute
hi I'm Rachel I'm representing the u.s.
today and we are going to be swapping
snacks snacks
swap with snacks I have zero zero idea
what you guys would eat for snacks like
I haven't just imagine everything
delicious that's what we eat so this is
next I've delicious let's get to it
let's do it I'm hungry too this time to
eat no no no no no no because first
we're gonna talk about this is the
presentation so I'm already starting off
bad have you ever had a lunch hell no
I'm giving you this cutting board with
grease seening you take the prosciutto
you roll it around the bread and then
you buy in the first thing you have its
the saltiness and the beautiful flavor
of the prosciutto and the more you have
the flavor of the bread underneath today
it kind of cleans your palate and this
is per year this is special
prosciutto I don't think it's a
competition let's not make a competition
because it's a cover it wouldn't be fair
this is not this Michael oh but enjoy I
did not lean into that well it is gonna
go great for you thank you very much
yeah yeah so you guys know this I'm
heading back and I get it I get to enjoy
your you got a rule little shipped
around the bread around across the scene
yes you can make like a little sandwich
you could put the turkey turkey wheat
oh I'm smelling the sauce how you know
butter sauce no this is so neat you know
it's overall the most important flavor
do a poop first cheese I'll do me
however I like weird stuff it's good
[Music]
the seasoning on the sauce is way too
strong I'm not tasting and the cheese is
cheese it becames just a structure on
the thing and lipid oniy is terrible I
think these are good they're pretty
lightweight I feel like I would be able
to dip stuff with this I wish I still
ain't mean cuz I could wrap it around
but these are really good but how do you
feel about the experience you feel like
a chef
no for lunch
or yeah carry it with me yeah oh it's
definitely a little no good definitely
that we got a coke here this is just
like one of the biggest brands the world
in the world this is something that
pretty much everybody has had at one
moment in time to America you know what
I mean if by ever after so the keynote
story is my little Kino Kino is amazing
it comes from Vermont kind of an orange
it's an acquired taste so I don't know
if you're gonna like is it orange it's
all it's a kind of an orange is a kind
of an honor it's kind of like Peter I'm
excited about this please try this it's
my gift
classically it's the sound that's what
they go for right yeah fit am I gonna
get fancy from this oh this smells
better I can't even drink it I spell it
over myself
look at this oh it's good it's weird and
it's good
oh this isn't bad yeah it is turn this
yeah it's like a little bit I got that
I'm gonna be a little yeah it's not bad
at all did your life change I think I
never drink soda in the morning
well chinotto is uh it's pretty solid
and it's super Italian so that kind of
orange family is really yeah I feel like
for this one we probably are gonna try
to have a draw I feel like I don't know
no no my favorite drinks in the whole
world
I love it it's not as bubbly but when
you first drink it it's like oh this is
soda and then it's like oh this is
changing and now it has like that
citrusy sort of aftertaste which is
like interesting maybe off the same to
me I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be put
one about the other but I do see what
you're saying this is like it's it's a
little more it's a little more something
going on here I think I just means I
okay okay out of the two I would choose
this one he's one day aftertaste will
leaves you in the mouth it's for the
best part it's kind of dryness sweetness
is so good I want to internet I'm great
good job honey I'm excited about both of
these so this is what I was talking
about like the first sex was a hundred
percent your type of stag savory bread
this is me right here in Italy we told
these men in viña it's like little Mike
these are like I'm in my bed at 11:30
p.m. and you're just watching Netflix
saying you ain't no one by one one gulp
like literally just like I never had one
but they're pretty famous they're more
famous than most people open air and fun
all right
we're trying this out it smell delicious
it smells amazing it smells delicious I
gotta be honest this smells a little bit
I'm excited for you good this is better
than a cupcake to me because the
frosting is inside so it's a better
experience because you bite into the
bread and that is something they
discover inside for this one it's like
not very sweet it's not overwhelming at
all
I think this these days really similar
it's definitely a little less filling in
there that's gone but it tastes very
similar I know that was a good catch
how would it be like Frankie I'm gonna
show you how you eat it okay right
more like come all yours well that's a
skill I don't know if I can do it I
think the frosting is out then because
he has more liquid I think I'm gonna
choke I try it just for the sake of
experimentation
just make it out of the chew I would
choose this one just because I just like
can't like it's just very sweet so sweet
out of every snare top I've ever done
this is probably the closest snack how'd
that work out there taste bouncing
yeah why that sounds a devilish why did
you laugh like that I don't know if I'm
gonna give it to you so this is king bed
oil but I keep one in my fridge just
sometimes you need a hug and there's
nobody around you let Okita Brenner
it's very crunchy outside and then kind
of like amazing inside gooey like it's
no secret it's great I feel like out of
chocolate I like it the best because it
has like the caramel on the nuts and
stuff like that's it is that good blend
what I like about these already is that
the gotta where you can just separate
them off so you just want to get one
real quick you can fix that I like that
it's good it's very light
it's very good what's a filling that can
oh it's good
forget it oh it is in hazelnut do you
know I'm not a hazelnut person but I'm
still gonna mess with this this is so
good
it's so much lighter this is great
what's going on
it's a journey but to clean your mouth
there's so much going on stick to your
teeth it's not like oh maybe that's nice
guys
magic five when I have a snake there you
have to me okay this is great really
light not really comparable to anything
that I can think of that we have at
America's like it's not it has like that
wafer or whatever like a KitKat but it
isn't a KitKat it all I've seen a thing
I feel like I have to eat in one of them
I will probably just eat one at a time
yeah you don't want to eat both usually
it's someone that's why they know it's
because one it's really fulfilling is
right I think I would pick this me I
would pick this this is I think it's a
real thought-out
snack like there's a guy be like okay
when I start with a chocolate and then
go crunchy and then we're gonna have
something going sweet inside and then
it's perhaps in like but wait when you
get to take a break what if you only was
eaten one but a warning to betray
wrapper work who to so people can yes
perfect so if I'd it's using DEFCON
vikander
sorry guys no not no not to the Snickers
people are there I love it
it's great
[Music]
I think it was great to be able to see
different things like the sweets really
cool and the drink that I had never
tried before the now I'm really pumped
about also I feel like it was a pretty
delicate balance of like burning more
but also seeing a lot of similarities
which was yeah well overall I'm gonna
say you guys probably take a pair day
I'm not gonna lie pti checking for today
I came in to really like to be open and
to see what you guys got and I was very
excited to be here
you know we appreciate you guys inviting
Italy here we knew that we came in
strong from our background and I think
we want but it's you guys participated
and that's what's important I'm looking
forward your future in food and you guys
gonna do great
[Music]